- [Instructor] With its gold
color and stunning rings,
Saturn is quite a planetary gem.
Saturn is the second-largest
of the eight planets,
and it is about ten
times as wide as Earth.
Despite its size, Saturn is
actually the lightest planet.
It is predominantly made of
the gases hydrogen and helium.
And because of its particular
gaseous composition,
Saturn is the only planet
in the solar system
that's less dense than water.
If the planet were placed
on an enormous ocean,
it would be able to float.
Saturn's gaseous makeup also means
that it has no true surface.
At its center, the planet has a dense core
of water, ice, and rocky material,
but it has no actual landmass.
Instead, it's mostly
made of gases, liquids,
and yellow ammonia crystals
that swirl around the planet,
creating golden clouds and storms.
The largest storm on Saturn
is at its north pole.
It's over twice the size of Earth
and shaped in a near-perfect hexagon.
Each of the six sides is believed
to be the result of jet streams,
which all encircle a massive hurricane.
Because of Saturn's
inhospitable environment,
the planet cannot support life -
but some of its moons might.
Saturn has more than 50 confirmed moons,
and each varies in size and terrain.
Enceladus, one of Saturn's smallest moons,
is covered in ice and only about
as wide as the state of Pennsylvania.
Titan, Saturn's largest moon,
is nearly as wide as Canada.
Titan is also the only
moon in the solar system
with clouds and a dense atmosphere.
Both Titan and Enceladus
have underground oceans
that would make them potentially
capable of sustaining life.
Saturn's moons may also
play a role in shaping
the planet's signature feature: its rings.
Saturn's ring system is the largest
and most complex in the
entire solar system.
The rings are made of
icy and rocky remnants
from comets, asteroids, and moons.
The particles range in size
from being as small as dust
to as big as mountains.
The ring system is divided
into seven groups of rings.
Altogether, they are as wide
as four-and-a-half Earths,
but only about two-thirds of a mile thick.
How the rings are able to
stay on track and intact
has to do with Saturn's smallest moons.
Called Shepherding moons,
these tiny satellites
orbit between the rings,
and they seem to use their gravity
to shape the ring material
into circular paths.
Saturn has fascinated scientists
and amateur astronomers
alike for thousands of years.
The ancient Greeks and Romans,
who named the planet after
their god of agriculture,
believed it was a star.
It wasn't until the 17th century,
after the telescope was invented,
that scientists like Galileo Galilei,
Christiaan Huygens, and Giovanni Cassini
could take a much closer look.
Only then was Saturn's
planetary status discovered
and, ultimately, its many
moons and brilliant rings.
Because of its planet-like moons,
lightweight composition,
and dazzling ring system,
Saturn continues to
mesmerize us to this day.